the purpose of this evening is to do is
to discuss this object which has just
come out and what the subject means what
it do does how it works why was done and
what I think you'll discover is the way
in which this particular document
doesn't fit into the standard sort of
stereotype of the dance between books
and buildings in our field and as such
as part of an extended experiment and an
experiment in this case guided by by amo
and and an extended series of partners
throughout the Middle East so basically
the the way the evening will work is I
will shut up Todd will explain to you
what's going on in the in these 536
pages it's a very heavy document just to
say the obvious to you very quickly of
course books generally take longer than
buildings to make and they're almost
always heavier and this is no exception
so we're going to move very fast and
hard tonight but almost the purpose here
is is to give you as it were a kind of a
report on on what this kind of work is
about and why this kind of work is
operating the way it might go and in
particular maybe to think about the kind
of feedback loops that might emerge out
of this kind of work and the ways in
which perhaps new species of architect
or others other kinds of species might
emerge as it were in the shadow of this
kind of work so firstly Todd will
explain the the thinking behind this
document and how it works and remco
house will also explain it from his
perspective then we'll spend about half
an hour discussing it which would be
largely between ourselves and then there
will be an appallingly short period in
which we will simulate democracy and you
will ask questions which will be
answered scathingly
and but also with a certain degree of
tenderness because we understand that
this is going to be always too short and
we would take your frustration at the
end as it as a as a great compliment I
think that the almond acres is
shockingly good document and the reason
I think it's shockingly good is that it
very very quickly defeats a whole series
of standard assumptions you might have
about what constitutes research in this
field so it's incredibly it's a great
honor I think to listen to Todd and RAM
explained the thinking behind this
document which is not produced in the
way you might imagine and I think its
effects and not necessarily what the
people who did contribute to it might
imagine either so let's begin the
discussion with time
I could eat good evening this working
nope now it is now to start with I guess
first its to be understood that Almanac
is is not a book it's actually a project
the project we started in 2007 with a
number of parties involved one being OMA
amo another being a group called pink
tank which is a think tank operating and
Dubai and the third is volume magazine
which is in itself another group of
people including volume magazine amo and
of course Columbia University and we
were interested in kind of pursuing
further development of our ongoing
research of the region in 2007 and we
were thinking of doing something like an
almanac I mean we discovered actually
that the word almanac presumably comes
from the Arabic world arabic word
almanac meaning climate i could also
mean atmosphere or the feeling of a
place and so we quickly found let's say
the name of our project Almanac to Gulf
continued is the name of the book it was
published this past May and it's a
follow-up to as I said the book we did
in 2007 and if 2007's book was a look at
the region from the outside looking in
and and digging into what actually is
there almanac to was very much the
opposite and finding a way to work with
people who were living and working there
and to project that outward we also have
a website which we developed during the
as a way of developing the book and it's
also something that we continue to use
as a way to continue discussions about
the book we've also branched out into
working with the huffington post where
we maintain a blog that looks at
continues to find a new say readership
we find that every week more people read
more people read us every week here than
have bought the book which has been a
really generous way of reaching a public
especially in North America we also come
at a time when suddenly there are lots
of books about the region specifically
about Dubai ranging from things that try
to show a kind of city of Cataclysm to
the weirdest city and also ones that
even kind of start to suggest kind of
doom interesting enough a book that came
out by an American journalist this past
year takes on a strikingly different
image one in you in the UK which is a
country that is much more familiar with
Dubai than let's say the US and in the
u.s. Dubai is then still sold as this
kind of exotic place the city of gold as
opposed to on your left the city of grey
we've also been noticing it there was a
kind of error that seems to have passed
something that has earned the name Dubai
bashing which had was happening allowed
in the British press about to buy that
suddenly Dubai as a city became a kind
of a object in and of itself with
ignoring its kind of allowance of layers
of complexity but someone became a kind
of easily misconstrued or hated monster
and these are just a few of them ranging
from obvious fictions to the revelation
ille and then even to the kind of
prophecy at the at the epic proportion
of sand will drift down around their
trunkless legs and animals will inhabit
their basements and as almanac project
we simply catalogues doll cataloged all
of these kind of
very quick to judge moments that had
actually very little factual basis to
them and even continue on to today this
is just a few days ago in the London
Telegraph where it's suggesting that
there's going to be this kind of
cataclysmic event in the area near
future of buildings coming down which
was simply taken from a consultants mild
suggestion and a and a report
unsolicited by the city so just to kind
of give us a very simple idea of what
we're we're talking in the world and
Dubai is often referred to as a city
that represents this region namely known
as Arabia and it's rarely referred to as
a global city and sometimes it's
explicitly referred to as not a global
city but this seems to me a kind of
ridiculous notion to think of Dubai
without its global connections I think
to start with Dubai has been built by
knowledge primarily from the outside
however limited or advanced sometime
this information or this knowledge has
come from Great Britain sometimes from
the US Australia Japan Austria namely
North America and Europe it has been
also a place of investment and more
particularly labor source of from South
Asia India Pakistan Bangladesh and has
been financially pushed and supported by
just about every country with a majority
Islamic population and this is a way of
saying that for Dubai to fail there
would be more people outside of Dubai
that would suffer them in other words
Dubai represents a unique point in the
world with the powers that rarely align
move from miss communication to
communication the goals or results of
this of this process are by no means
utopian
they are banal and they're uh Nigel is
tick but they are ones that show a truly
global population that we haven't seen
for over 500 years and for this reason
we should be students of this region and
respectful observers but it's a it's
very important to understand that Dubai
is also working with in a regional
Network namely a group of cities on the
peninsula namely Kuwait manama Doha Abu
Dhabi and then three cities of Saudi
Arabia we've chosen here namely dammam
Riyadh and Jeddah and it's a it's a kind
of strange relationship by no means is
it can you see it as a kind of
collaborative effort among the cities
there's extreme amounts of duplication
but duplication is also a kind of
bizarre way of acknowledging that
something is right and I think this is
something that all minak two tries to do
it tries to show out to point out what
distinguishes these cities but by trying
to distinguish them you immediately see
see that they are actually working for
very similar goals I would say the
domina mo na 2 is one of the first books
first efforts to kind of start to see
this emerging constellation of cities
and what they will mean in the future
when we first started this book that
were the first evidence of crisis and
they immediately put our project into
crisis we were rather optimistic perhaps
foolishly at the idea of projecting this
region as some place where we knew it
was going and we simply found ourselves
not having any clue where it was going
suddenly propelled projects were coming
to a standstill
buildings became ruins before they were
even finished at the same time being
like it's my watch it's only a swatch so
at the same time of the crisis it was
all so ironically a time when sudden
amounts of housing and buildings were
becoming coming online and being
inhabited Dubai as a digital rendering
was becoming lived in and suddenly the
kind of the weird moments the the kind
of dissatisfactions about a reality will
be also becoming something we could we
could measure this is a famous one of
the biggest developers and some of the
most kind of disappointing disappointed
residents I should say of the new Dubai
and strangely enough at the same time
that crisis was abounding suddenly
neighborhoods that were once some of the
most lively most fully serviced by
infrastructure were being demolished for
new development a really on a tragic
moment and these these sites are now
completely vacant within the heart of
the city but I think one thing we also
should to note about to buy is that
there was a an economy that quickly
started to have to face a reality at the
same time there was another economy
another world of Dubai that continued as
if it never really mattered what had
happened on the other edges city this is
the old Dubai as they say this is the
debar that was always a global Dubai
connected to Asia connected to Africa
and the rest of the Middle East this
part of Dubai continues to thrive
mark made a joke about the length of
days length of time that takes to make a
book this is how many days it took to
make this book I think it's pretty fast
considering other than the first day we
had no idea what the book was going to
be about and with the the point of
crisis we also started to take on a very
serious effort to to record the news and
to try to map out let's say trends of
what was happening try to find the
people who had something to say about
what was going on it was a chaotic
moment not only for the world but for
Dubai where media is always a kind of
and then not just a bar but also the
region a kind of unpredictable source of
information this is one of the reviews
that we had of Almanac to and I don't
know if it's meant in a good way or a
bad way but we were told that we dropped
the gamer graphics I mean went for the
aesthetic of an international urban
conference and that the book is as dry
as a desert road linking dubai to Abu
Dhabi it's a pretty dry road
in essence though I think it wasn't it
wasn't an intentional point of our
effort for the book we didn't
necessarily aim for a black and white
book but in the end I think it was a way
of a way of reacting to let's say an
image ladened way of understanding the
region and suddenly being able to find
people who could project a story with
words we went out we met people in
Riyadh and Jeddah in Dubai and Doha and
really started to kind of iron out kind
of what the issues were there was a
tiresome process but also incredibly
informative it led to the hugely immense
amount of people who contributed to this
book over a hundred and forty people
contributed in some way to this book
which for us was an entirely different
way of working we went from doing most
of the work for the first Almanac mostly
in the amo office to suddenly having to
build up a network of people not only
from the region but also reporting from
other places for north north america
from Asia Europe and Africa about about
the region I just wanted to quickly
touch upon three significant things
about the book one is that we introduced
Saudi Arabia which was a huge effort on
our part to to kind of take it on and an
amazing way we found so many people who
were willing to trust us and to work
with us to make this to make the story
right but it was a very difficult
process because there is so much Saudi
Arabia is pursuing the the development
of six economic cities built for
millions of people this is a these are
kind of new cities that the Gulf has
never seen before except in Saudi Arabia
we were also starting to kind of find
moments of
normal normality and in Saudi Arabia
this being a public park which kind of
suddenly starts to just a single image
we found started to transform our image
of what daily life is in Riyadh we also
started to find institutions that are
being developed in Saudi Arabia this is
the King Abdullah University of Science
and Technology suddenly a huge effort I
can't get into today but potentially
transforming the notion of what how we
see universities again to get this part
of every day we found a female
photographer one of a photographer who's
a psychotherapist one of the few psycho
therapists in Saudi Arabia she was the
first person ever to photograph the
interiors of the only train in Arabia
which connects Riyadh to the Gulf Coast
it's the only place public space where
it's so easy easy to for men and women
to interact and suddenly trains be kind
of looking at spaces like a train become
ways of understanding not only how
people live but also that that there is
a normal place and instead of looking
for ways of providing criticism about
cities in insider we look we look for
people who are actually there who are
providing criticism not only toward the
outside but within this city and this is
a man in Jeddah mitsui Gary there is a
popular TV show and he's continuously
kind of pressing social norms through
his very brief and and comedic TV shows
one of the other issues that we took on
in the book was again with a topic that
we addressed annulment up one which is
something that is often kind of
the story that we hear most that being
of course the the condition of laborers
interesting enough this was in the news
just this week about the Guggenheim
promising in Abu Dhabi that they will
commit to protecting the rights of
migrant workers as if it's so clear what
the rights of migrant workers are and
such a kind of complex international
system to even suggest that there is a
way to measure that is is ridiculous
while at the same time having to to
commend what they're suggesting here in
Almanac one we we looked at where these
men lived and we were actually found
that you know what's often called hidden
Dubai is very much an exposed by a place
where anyone can go and and visit it's
these are simply other kinds of
neighborhoods in the city with almond f2
we also decided okay let's really look
at this relationship of the Gulf with
these other countries where these
unskilled laborers are coming from
namely of course India Pakistan
Indonesia Sri Lanka and we started to
look at ways of measuring this money and
we quickly found there's no way to
measure this money these are all just
very rough estimates so we decided to
take one region of india kerala which is
a painted it red on the map here kerala
is obviously a small fraction of india
two-thirds of dubai comes from india
two-thirds of the population comes from
kerala that means like roughly one in
six people you've come across in the UAE
is from this little part of india so we
went he went with a an architect who
grew up in
Dubai but is from Kerala and we took a
look took a trip along this this
coastline which is the only highway of
Kerala and is often noted as the highway
that's developed because of the Gulf
almost every Street has a money transfer
station where the money money transfers
from men working in the in the region
this is going to this is where families
pick it up these places are just
constantly constantly busy a common
presence in any kind of public building
is Gandhi with the founding father of
the UAE this is a totally normal
condition dubai takes on a kind of
mystique the kind of representation of
success and of luxury the name is
everywhere it's a it's represented with
a kind of obsession not only with
materialistic game but also a kind of
movement away and this is just a one
example from the book where we went to
this town called pion gotti which is
probably a few hundred people it's a one
road town and we walked down with the
guy who lives here I mean we he pointed
at each of these houses every single
house had a relationship with the Gulf a
father working in Saudi Arabia kids
working in Doha daughter married to a
man working in Dubai so every single
house was built with Gulf money houses
like this are a dime a dozen in Kerala
this is the home of a doctor who
educated in Kerala found his way into a
successful career in Dubai there they
have a name they're called Gulf houses
and they range anywhere between these
two kinds of houses and we shun quite a
few of them in the book so I I think
what we wanted to show with this kind of
trip to Carol eyes well of course there
a lot of inequalities a lot of in
terrible stories and what can happen
it's a much more complex story and
interestingly enough from the West
you'll hear about the knee problems of
poverty and the problems of inequality
that that drive the system you talk to
people in India the complaint is this
connection to the Gulf is a kind of
increase in materialism a kind of
addiction to an easy cash i kind of
obviously there's a problem but what
that problem is is it seems to have two
different two different currents the
third topic that i just wanted to bring
up is the notion of a united Gulf one
that is completely a at this point naive
thing to suggest but there is a GCC rail
proposed and a writer of tabatha Decker
looked at the the GCC rail which will be
connecting the different Gulf cities we
also started to see that this will
potentially set up at linking not only
among these cities but into North Africa
and the Middle East and it starts to
suggests to kind of return to something
that hasn't been talked about for
several decades and that is the notion
of infrastructure infrastructure of
course was Dubai was a big story of for
infrastructure this past year with the
opening of the Metro a story that had
its own kind of stories of trials and
and and mistakes and warnings that it
would never work that all these
different kinds of people would never
sit in the same kind of train that that
rich and poor could never could never
sit together that man woman could never
sit together however it quickly just
becomes part of what to buy is and it
suddenly become a place that the sorry
the metro has suddenly become a place
that has kind of adapted to Dubai but
Dubai has adapted to it and it becomes
kind of public space for to buy that it
actually has never had and it starts to
remind me of kind of the the initial
notions of infrastructure that were
being developed in the region this is a
picture from the early 60s this is the
development of a British engineers of a
camel trough in the desert of Saudi
Arabia a kind of bizarre piece of
infrastructure that would eventually
have to find it that people using would
have to find its use to have to start to
adjust to what it means to use this new
piece of infrastructure and it starts to
me it also reminds me of this is a
picture of Dubai in early 1960s one of
the first roundabouts and one of the
first pieces of asphalt laid in the Gulf
it starts to suggest that infrastructure
while it's concrete and steel often kind
of leis leis the ground for other things
to happen namely social and cultural and
while as the GCC railway starts to
develop this is something that will
connect to it some new rail stations
being developed in Saudi Arabia and if
you look at any sort of renderings being
developed for the Gulf this is you
couldn't be any more generic and how
they're represented as if everyone has
to have the Damascus souk roof and gold
is always a color so it's a very generic
rendering but it also starts to suggest
that perhaps architecture is not what's
going to do it but the kind of the
planning and the end and the laying of
infrastructure as a way to start
suggesting how these cities will begin
to evolve and I just wanted to end with
one of my favorite picture
from the book which kind of shows you
the unique quality but also the kind of
banal or normal normality of life this
is Abu Dhabi one of the most diverse
crowds of people I've seen for one of
the most banal events a motor boat race
thank
essentially I want to compliment Todd
and explain to you why office or why I
myself remain very obstinate in
maintaining our engagement with the Gulf
it is not strictly altruistic but there
are elements of idealism involved in
this constant preoccupation but I want
to really show the context of our
involvement the way I see it and
therefore the extent to which this is
economically serious effort with
political overtones after 911 it seemed
that in a way American America would
separate itself from the rest of the
world and that therefore Rosh Hashanah
in the other Arab world and Europe were
not only condemned to each other but
were on the brink of engaging in new
kind of partnerships and perhaps a new
intimacy but of course the difficulty is
that we are all enjoying very different
political systems and what became clear
since
19 2000 one is of course that we're in
89 with a full of the wall the West was
simply assuming that in the imminent
future the entire world would turn a
light blue that as time goes along and
that would be the end of history but as
time goes along we see more and more
that actually what is blue now may stay
blue but that what is wet and yellow is
not likely to become blue in the
immediate future and so that is a kind
of very harsh neuken reality that needs
to be engaged and which in my view made
it even more compelling and origin that
all these opposite political systems
remain engaged with each other and
communicate this is a kind of something
we're in the context of the European
Union I have been very very adamant but
completely unsuccessful but part of my
persona in the past five years has been
to be involved in the color policymaking
of Europe I was part of a particular
group that needed to define where Europe
was going and in that my role was an
advocate for this continued involvement
and that advocacy takes place takes the
form of many forms it is about
communication in and with China color
partly through buildings but also partly
through performance it is about
communication in and with Russia in this
case it is an educational initiative
that we are introducing in Moscow where
we will start a three-year-long
experiment with a research-based
architectural education that
commits itself to finding out and
defining a number of crucial issue is
not only in Russia but also in the world
the what is the status of preservation
what happens in design energy and public
space it speaks for itself but all of
this is kind of simply part of the
continuing involvement with these worlds
and in that the Arab world is no
exception and in fact perhaps the one
where I've invested my most personal
feelings now as I already mentioned this
advocacy particularly in Europe is
completely unsuccessful and on the
contrary we may be facing kind of
situation through the crisis where the
Atlantic world separates itself from the
rest of the world kind of simply by its
and through its going to be landless
anti-islamic rhetoric recently one of
the most notorious Dutch politicians
spoke on Times Square these were his
words one of the chairman of the German
bank had to resign because he was
quoting words over kind of similar
nature the combined wisdom and wet awake
of the European leaders is come simply
to appalling forwards kind of really
revolting so we are facing a kind of a
incredible moment of extreme political
mediocrity to put it positively and
negativity to put it
badly we're simply Europe is kind of
turning its back to commitments that
were made much more early and we're in
nearly racist polemic countries like
Switzerland forbids minarets and where
this is can maybe speaks for itself a
computer game in Austria where the point
is to kill as many mullahs as possible I
what what is kind of really staggering
is that kind of simply because we are
talking here about Islam that this is
considered more or less done and and not
not as offensive as it would be if other
groups or populations were aimed at the
same thing is of course unfortunately
two in America and what has kind of
shocked me is that even highbrow media
such as the new york review of books but
that recently published review of some
of the dubai books that thought was can
really showing by a newsweek newsweek
journalist joshua hammer is put taking
part of it and for me there were two
sentences that were really deeply
revealing in one of them a taxi driver
is from pakistan is quoted as the
situation is very bad here I found it
really really deeply shocking that an
intellectual magazine quoted taxi driver
you know which is the old trick of
Connor spreading malicious lies that the
journalists have used and that another
amazing curve statement as an indictment
against Dubai was that kind of American
stick with Americans Brits with brits
onions with aliens everyone keeps to his
own kind as if the situation
different anywhere else in the world and
actually totals also showing that in
trans metros & sports event we there is
actual actually a mix that is more
profound FMS if you look at an audience
here then there than it is here so this
in a way insistence on communication is
is what is driving our commitment to
still maintaining the interest in the
Gulf even though seemingly it is over
and in the first wave we introduced in
the morale and Venice the daring theory
that the rulers of the Gulf know what
they were doing and that they were
deeply personally involved in the entire
effort now we are documenting that
actually you know in in do with all the
mosque minaret trouble in America and
Europe that there is many many churches
in the in the airport that bishops speak
there that there are religious people
and to the extent that Dubai is perhaps
a strange city I don't think that its
strangeness is unique to do I but
believe that what we are seeing there
almost as a kind of laboratory is the
strange and maybe visit there earlier is
a strangeness which more and more of our
cities will show an accommodate one of
the things that kind of haunts me can
recently is the sensation that many new
cities are not really permanently
inhabited and that perhaps in the future
the canal pneumatic status of so many of
citizens will cause a situation where
no city will be inhabited with the kind
of density that we remember from kind of
earlier iterations of city and in Dubai
if you want to kind of show for signs of
an invitation you're kind of really
hard-pressed so in the end we decided to
call in a petition irregularity and
we're tracing points of irregularity
kind of tiny shift of an object on a
balcony or window or curtain so but I
think that this evacuation of the city
and the simultaneous evacuation of the
countryside will be one of the big
themes of the next kind of decades and
Dubai is only an early example now in
the context of this commitment we are
committing ourselves to working as much
as possible in this region on projects
that are able to really capture the most
not so much extreme but the most unique
aspects of it we started briefly in the
initial kind of wave of euphoria Dubai
enabled us to kind of really address the
issue of Architects architectures
current addiction to shape and therefore
its imminent irrelevance by kind of
suggesting on this spot a building that
would kind of break really radically and
brutally with the better addition the
so-called when I sense a huge slab of
white concrete 200 x 300 meters it would
also rotate that without dubai and
without the crisis that was visible and
tangible in dubai we would never have
been able to imagine it and also it was
for us a wake-up call I would say in
terms of our
work and future direction we are trying
it's not happening in Dubai but kind of
perhaps it will happen in Riyadh and
that we're kind of experimenting this
was the original facade maybe it will
change slightly or radically another
kind of project is unable to to find a
kind of vernacular scale and what do I
also enabled us to kind of think about
was that if a city is so profoundly
unserious and if it is so marginally
determined by planning in the classical
sense of the word what are then the kind
of devices and what are then the
mechanisms that could somehow define its
future and so we looked at NASA and
could have proposed a kind of a
real-time planning and urbanism we're
given the fact that no plans could be
implemented and that even if implemented
chaos was a certainty that planning
could become color posters of permanent
improvisation and to make somehow the
aberrations work so that again was part
of dubai's richness Dubai was the only
environment and is still the only
environment where we can do mass housing
we were asked to do mass housing cheap
housing no one in 20 years would even
dream to ask us to do a thing like that
in Dubai it's happening do I also enable
this to experiment with preservation for
the first time maybe not in the
classical sense of the word not
necessarily preserving masterpieces or
beauty or but preserving
a dignified thought was already talking
about it and beautiful form a very
intricate almost village like life in at
the foot of these skyscrapers where this
contrast we wanted to maintain and so
when we looked at empty and bald patches
in that pattern would maybe going to
develop them or even extremely develop
them or find a kind of crop rotation
where you could make sure that bands of
the old stuff would exist and coexist
with no stop but anyway it is a city
where this kind of experimentation is
perhaps possible and useful I want to
show maybe two other efforts that are
maybe more typical of the current moment
in Arab world where this drive for
development is abating and we're there
for other issues and issues of how to
keep what is there and how to think
about preserving not only cities but but
actually the physical conditions of the
city and I want to talk to about Libya
that's how far we go in in this map
everything which is yellow is connected
to civilization and everything which is
wet is disconnected so this is Libya
here so a considerable part of it is
disconnected from it is desert but even
in the desert of course there are paths
in Libya we are presenting first of all
observing thought has made a long
journey through the entire desert kind
of documenting all the parts but also
all the phenomena there
and all the fragilities that are being
exposed to tourism and to invasion of
foreigners this is a kind of German
methodology a kind of aunt Arctic twerk
that brings all the beer and worst that
is necessary for an autonomous existence
in the desert but that then Rex Havelock
vehicle beauty of places like this and
understand even if superficial leads
it's not really damage but damage that
will take literally centuries to undo
similarly there are kind of works and
cave caves and in caves all right in
these caves among the oldest that
mankind knows but it's unprotected and
therefore very fragile so what we are
kind of working on is three national
parks report this is a proposal and and
write scenarios in those color proposals
how these perks should be treated where
there is excess umbrella would be no
access the kind of lightness and
sensitivity of using any of these perks
and a particular effort that in order to
unlock them we only use over the
existing infrastructure so that we are
not contributing to further degradation
and and these are our proposals you know
that range from doing nothing to a
desert station and to really notes of a
degree of tourism so it's as we
formulated it it's not tourism but the
tourist is turned it to a traveler and
these are then can responsible tools to
offer a traveler
in return for kind of sensitivity to the
landscape I have done something that I
thought would be impossible to become
part of a scientific committee to
preserve help to preserve the
inheritance of how some fatty the
Egyptian architect his sustainable
village is in dire trouble and needs to
be kind of rescued and finally and this
is going to rush we are working in Syria
these are archaeological sites and
Sierra's a country of literally
unimaginable richness these are all the
Roman sites and this is Syria with a
kind of belt an arc of the green and and
then a hard land of desert in the
heartland there is this palmera an
unbelievably beautiful city room which
is particularly beautiful because it is
again completely non touristic there are
no facilities it's simply there in the
desert and and somehow our commission is
to think of how that beauty could be
maintained
as long as possible a further kind of
thing that we're kind of trying to do
there is to find ways in which the
typical difference that you see here and
which is one of those kind of poisonous
by effects of preservation is that it
kind of radically changes the nature of
what you wanted to preserve this is a
used space in Damascus and this is a
preserved space in Damascus and and of
course our heart is always here but as
architects the moment we touch it or
think about it or even look at it it has
a tendency to turn into this condition
so our are we are looking for ways of
out of that dilemma and and we think we
have found perhaps one of these places
we're kind of at and do something
exceptional another kind of icon another
kind of regional building we found an
abandoned structure that is there from
dating from the 80s in the center of the
city kind of really and in itself quite
beautiful that nobody knows what to do
with so we've basically asked but we
could take over this room and and maybe
and simply make our statement by
slightly converting it and
making better contribution to the city
so this is kind of simply a breakneck
place to journey to kind of simply
explain in which political context we
think this is an important engagement
and also to show how architectural II
the effects of that engagement are one
of a constant extension of our
repertoire and simply by confronting is
with situations that we could never
imagine before thank you
so in a way just a few minutes to try to
in a way figure out the relationship
between the two presentations and I mean
this is this is volume number 23 and I
think I'm neck one was volume 12 so in a
way you can now measure the volume
project by the almanacs the almanacs
like the weather they arrive in a
certain frequency and this one is very
different from the first one so it seems
to be this within the almanac project
there is a kind of self self reflection
and and the thing is as evolved so I
suppose in volume member whatever it
would be the almanac three would change
again but still not clear to me the
exactly the relationship between this
document let's say and and let's say the
the work of this of the studio on the
one hand volume belongs to the to the
mo-om a kind of confusion and on the
other hand it's a separate project in
you know almost volume was constructed
to make it possible for there to be
separate projects so somehow it drifts
away from you guys and then it's also
somehow reappears like Todd reappears in
the desert towards the end of your
presentation so I'm trying to figure out
that the geometry of this another way to
ask the same question would be in in a
certain way what you are saying Todd is
that is that you guys didn't write this
that you edited this and your
intelligence involved locating the
people who could tell the story so this
is actually much more story written from
the Middle East and then about the
Middle East it's sort of like a story as
told by those already changed by the
Middle East which makes sense of the
fact that it's even sponsored by UPC and
so on so I guess I'm just trying to
figure all this out and the reason i
think it's worth asking these kind of
boring questions is that the whole word
research has been super devalued in our
field because it's used every two
minutes and so on the one hand this
constant refrain of research there's
probably not an architect on the planet
that doesn't say that what they're doing
is research and on the one hand it's
sort of honorable like it's the chanting
the claim as old as Vitruvius that the
architect is an intellectual on the
other hand if you chant that often what
seems to be a confident claim is
actually a little bit more nervous claim
and actually the almost the word
research it starts to in a way pass
through the areas of the greatest doubt
in our field so in a way exactly when
architects confidently assert to
themselves to their clients to their
readers and so on that they're doing
research and that somehow then lens
their objects a certain special magic
their research has almost walked over
happily but blindly some of the biggest
challenges facing the species of
architects so if I could make this a
simple question
it seems to me that Ram that as you go
further and further into the desert
literally the work is less and less
predictable I mean less and less let's
say predictable if what you're expecting
is the work of an architect so its its
its preservation then it becomes
preservation of an architect I mean it's
all these other things so somehow i sigh
I think there has to be actually a
feedback loop stronger than you suggest
between this document that you let other
people right and the work that you
yourself are most actively doing the
work that you would keep as close to you
as possible which is further and further
away from what architects thought that
they were supposed to be doing well I
would like to say that of course my
entire life I've pursued two things with
almost equal passion one is well
producing books and the second one is to
produce architecture and
I really would prefer to think of this
as a book rather than research because
it's kind of really i think that the
percentage of architects participating
this whole book is actually negligible
it's gone really a book by writers
mostly and journalists and and therefore
i really prefer to turn terminology book
and i don't want to be either kind of
mystical or superficial about kind of
suggesting the connection the connection
is to simply be involved in the in the
two experiences on one hand almost every
single waking moments is spent in the
world as a writer and and for instance
trying to look for signs of a regularity
in devices seemingly impenetrable as
surface is really an activity over
writer and if i look in the swiss
countryside and see that can abilities
there have the same kind of curious
deafness and that there are two signs of
irregularity are getting kind of less
and less you know as a whiter i'm able
to draw specular create certain
speculations as to why that might happen
and bought it what is actually happening
so all that part of thinking i would say
it's kind of really more do thinking of
a Jonas to /a /s a writer what are them
and and maybe in certain cases
somebody thinking in fictional of terms
of friction rather than the crew to
preparations for eventual architectural
kind of efforts and what I try to show
this this evening is that nevertheless
the same experience can kind of lead or
few or give energy to particular
architecture effort and were you on that
time your job is safe a top didn't work
for us what do you think I do agree i
think also one word that we often use it
at volume is broadcasting actually friar
came from columbia the notion of that it
that it's not always about research but
it's about finding a way of extending an
idea of putting something on the table
to discuss and the only time the word
research came up in this project was
research for the book and it wasn't a
project about it's a influencing design
but it's definitely a product that we
were hoping would become a say a
document to be discussed within a field
of urbanism of architecture but what is
extremely good for us is that this book
is read voraciously there and discussed
ferociously there more there than more
than any year
and maybe really think that even is kind
of very appropriate and and I think that
what what what the book really shows is
that in spite of all the external
appearances that sometimes can suggest
stagnation or theatre anism regressive
nuh SAT and dog dogmatism that there is
at the same time I'm very vigorous
sometimes shapeless wave of modernity
and modernization well that is to which
particularly the younger generations are
extremely committed and they obviously
are wanting to bring to the particular
end in that sense I think that may be
one of the beautiful effects of the
crisis will be that this huge army of
consultants and this huge Atlantic let's
use that word script writing for the
region well now we see it and since our
there are fewer kind of optimistic
reasons to to be involved and and and
that it can find its own level I mean
I'm I'm wanting to cling a little bit to
your separation of the book from
research because there I mean if if that
makes if what you just did by separating
them makes sense ninety-five percent of
what's said about what architects right
is at risk for example the dimension of
this is more or less the same as
Siegfried Gillian space-time an
architecture actually
within 10 pages of the first edition so
it's all designed so I could fit in a
mailbox yeah pay attention but it freaks
out I mean or let's say it another way I
mean there are lots people have spent
the last 20 years inventing
uninteresting ways to describe your work
and they've really explored most options
but this seems to me the standard way to
be uninteresting about your work is to
try to draw a one-to-one connection
between the books and the buildings as
if one tries to explain or rationalize
or take responsibility for the other and
it's it when I hear you say when you
emphasize your you yourself as a writer
what I pick up on that is is actually
what's sort of going on there is much
more to do about the irresponsibility or
the ability of the book to escape from
the building and vice versa or or even
the more the combination of the two when
they pretend to aim at each other really
that they aim to miss so they pass each
other and that generates a sort of heat
momentary heat around which you operate
but though but those are again reading
back to all of those architects saying
I'm doing research I'm doing research
look at my window detail I can't tell
you how much research led to this
magnificence the what they what they
don't want to say is I'm a writer and
I've constructed that you mean they're
really trying to as way take that out
yes yeah with work what do you want me
to say I mean
now what can I say it's a bit cruel we
all agree that the term research is
abused by the architects profession and
and we we both probably have a certain
responsibility in doing that yes and
it's a bit cheap for for either of us
now to deflate a bubble that we were
probably partly responsible for
inflating so let's fun so so let us take
make you think it's its course and not
artificially accelerated process okay
but you know what you've acquired by
producing books okay but but one of the
pleasures of listening to you and
reading you is that you quite often
confess to something and then do it 10
times more like the confession even
creates the space I I mean because in a
way when you create mo armor in 1998 you
you you you created an image of symmetry
you know between the buildings and the
books between the research and the
objects and so on a symmetry which
aircars that which was there at the
beginning in as much as like all my
stats and whatever it is 75 and
delirious New Yorkers like three years
later but the research for their three
years before so there's always this it's
a image of symmetry between the two even
if you're going to prick that bubble
yourself not really because I'm always
not not the books armor is a kind of
totally different field but what we're
doing with the mo is going to be
reapplying architectural thinking two in
fields that needed to put that that
don't don't need buildings so that is
definition of Emma so I don't see a mo
as a kind of separation between book
/ research and buildings I see it more
as finding ways in applying the
intelligence of architecture in fields
outside architecture so maybe that is a
very simple clarification but but that
for me is the little symmetry or the
twinning of a melanoma and in books have
in a way nothing to do with that couple
there's nothing to do with oma and
nothing to do with a mo so being
belligerent well this book then is not
an mi book you just make sense I mean
make sense of what you're saying about
it letting it be written from the region
is distinct from an mi book like in your
quote or the the quote says they gave up
the mo graphics it's like a kind of it I
think that whatever but but what I would
like to resurrect is the moment that
poem was born basically a very promising
and
can respectable architectural magazine
which actually had as one of its
qualities to be able to make excursions
away from architecture for which it was
severely punished by its readers and
we're mostly our cadets Empire the
people who gave subsidies who we thought
that it was a magazine that needed to
limit itself to architecture and so be
basically there was a crisis and you
without as far as I know any money to
yourself in Europe representing an
institution I thought any money was
representing an architecture office and
so basically we made a construction that
not as ourselves but but respectively my
office in your institution could support
that effort and therefore I think it
still has that degree of autonomy and
independence of of us will be supported
but we are more comfy what is it painful
late father Godfather yeah Godfather's
then then owners would say okay so i
feel like i extracted my blood because
because that's what i meant at the very
beginning by trying to say this is not
exactly what might be expected of it is
it is neither a straight mo research
report in
in the line of the others it's in fact
different from the previous Almanac nor
is it an explanation exactly what you're
up to in the Middle East although that
we don't appear in right so it exists in
that in that in that experimental space
that that volume tried to create and but
having said all of that when you see
Todd in the desert and you see the
latest work you there is a feedback loop
yeah because the feedback so we go to
the audience this is five minutes of
democracy which is actually more than
the norm yeah
the Hermetic in nature monolithic and
with a huge emphasis on clean energy so
of course you have Dubai which is sort
of a version of this being realized and
then Abu Dhabi and I know at least one
more that sort of being vision in Riyadh
but you mentioned it was six I'm so a
little curious whether you see a
correlation between these cities and
sort of the gradual decline or depletion
of oil which is a lot of sort of like
the major export on all of these cities
and what that ultimately means for these
countries and what happens what would
the export be essentially when the oil
runs how is it sort of the idea is that
the technology where is this really you
know the ideas of the cities themselves
Saudi Arabia first of all is an entirely
different story than say abu dhabi abu
dhabi jeff had had the ambition to to
explore some ideas of sustainability I
think those are all at risk at this
point in time I'll just focus on Saudi
there are these six economic cities and
in the notion of these cities the kind
of the reason why they're on the table
is these cities are proposed as
solutions to problems naming problems
being one that oil will eventually run
out and that the money the being earned
through oil sales now needs to be
invested into things that will produce
new kinds of industries the other reason
why these cities are being built is that
Saudi Arabia unlike the rest of the Gulf
is exploring as experiencing a
population boom there's a growing youth
that's going to need jobs and these jobs
aren't just going to come from Aramco
and the oil fields and so there's a need
to diversify on this way and we do get a
and then that opens up a whole other
idea of kind of what a middle class
means in Sally let's just keep my answer
short there pretty fast yeah just far
away yeah
okay say one more somewhere like this is
a democracy so it has to be one from the
middle one from the left and one from
the right nothing from over here okay so
so our way in the back yo hi what would
be the the topic of your final lecture
it's a simple one simple question what
would be the topic of your final lecture
of our final lecture final one I have no
idea
dude you ever suggestion for the person
who asked the question we provide
psychotherapy had reduced rights your
desire that there be a last lecture I
mean I mean would it be about live work
or I really don't know but I'm to alive
to talk about life work anyway just to
thank everybody for coming into think
REM for not giving the final lecture
tonight and and I I want to join with
Raymond in congratulating tart on really
a fantastic book a book that's just as
troubling to a school of architecture as
it is to the figure of a professional
architect and I mean just to say in
almost by way of warning the degree of
intelligence of our field like most
fields may well may well be judged over
the next 20 years by the degree to which
we become less stupid about Saudi Arabia
and I really mean that and it's it's in
a way something to be proud of that that
from within the field of architecture
there was very very serious work done
towards that end and I think you guys
did a magnificent job thanks